ôz quelques années au Radiguet du
diableocp ou au rimbau d'une saison en
enfer vous aurez l'âge non pas du
capitaine mais de Michel Berger rien
d'infernal pourtant chez cet adolescent
des beau quartier le diable qui l'habite
ne lui souffle rien que très avoable ses
revendications le droit au twist ses
révoltes ell visent uniquement la
camomille et les tasses de
[Musique]
thé
j'aimerais me
promener avec des amis
ou bien aller
danser en surprise par
oui j'en ai
assez des danses de
thé
pourom en
famille des invitations
dans tous les
salons des faute de
Lou et des petits fours
oui j'en ai
assez de place de
thé pour les camam
ouais en
famille je n'ai pas encore
l'âge
m'embêter ah oui tournons la page ah moi
la liberté ouais ouais ouais
[Musique]
ouais vous ne comprenez
pas vous ne savez
pas
oh ce que c'est pour
moi mais maintenant c'est
fini je change de
vie je m'envê le
M retrouver les copain
oui j'en ai
assez les
[Musique]
en famille
oui j'en ai
[Musique]
assez